[Music]
so here's the story wolves are master
predators kings of the kill but when you
approach them they usually just back off
until now
in north america some wolves are getting
dangerously close way too close
i'm a tracker and i know when
something's not right in the woods
[Music]
i've got to find out what's going on
this is america
the wild
this is a great sign right here
you can see right here
where wolves fillet in the grass
chewed on this
vertebrae of some some mammal i don't
know what
and there's quite a bit of flesh and
greasiness stuck to these bones so good
news is we know there's wolves and
there's wolves very close to here right
now
[Music]
i'm on vargas island british columbia a
gorgeous place just north of vancouver
and i'm trying to track down some pretty
unusual wolves
little slippery on these boots
check this out
this is a great wolf track right here
the two lobes in the back four toes the
claws out in front
that is a great sign
so the wolves that live here are a
little different than the wolves i'm
used to back in yellowstone they're not
shy in fact everything i know about
wolves
is that they avoid humans at all costs
but here they're attacking people
they're attacking dogs
this is very different than anything
i've ever heard of
more now on those wolf attacks into fino
since friday two dogs have been preyed
upon by wolves i think there's just a
lot of fear in town
more now on tonight's top story the wolf
attack on vargas island a young man who
might not be alive tonight kayakers are
being warned by bc parks to be extra
careful around wolves
check it out check it out
folks around here are witnessing
strangely bold behavior in these wolves
oh my god they scared up a tree
and it turns out this area has more
aggressive wolf encounters in the past
decade than anywhere in north america
the one time i got too close to a wolf i
ended up with a lot of stitches
but that was a captive wolf
a wild wolf attacking a human
that's almost unheard of
tons and tons of tracks
so trailing these wolves things start to
build
this beach is covered in wolf tracks
they're everywhere so i know something's
going on here wolves just don't hang out
on the beach in one little spot so i
start to look around and then i see a
drag look right look right here right
here
that's why right there's a carcass
and right there in the seaweed
a fresh seal carcass
but they've been definitely feeding on
this
now i know that's a jackpot a wolf's a
wolf's a wolf and if there's food wolves
are coming back
i almost walked right by this thing
and then
in the forest right there
right there
in that thick forest
there's a wolf and we're between it
and it's carcass
[Music]
usually
they give out that call when they're
calling to their other pac members when
there's an emergency situation that
needs to be dealt with and at that point
they're talking about me
so this whole time that i'm down here
assessing the situation this wolf or
wolves
have been watching me from the trees
hanging out between a predator and its
kill isn't the greatest idea but this
might be my only chance to get close
shots of these wolves behavior
so i'm going to attach this camera as
secure as i can so they don't run off
with it
about the goofiest
camera trap setup i've ever
ever constructed here
good luck dude
get me some wolves
so now what i gotta do is just find the
natural path and what's so cool about
the beach is that there's a wolf highway
there's tracks everywhere so it's kind
of a no-brainer
give it a little
camo here
you're not working dude
keep working
there's wolves coming
good luck
night time is wolf time
my cameras are set
i just have to wait it out
but i'm a little cautious about spending
the night on the beach
this is right where that kayaker got
attacked by a wolf
it's the middle of the night
kayakers camping on the beach
the wolf approaches which is really
unusual
guy wakes up obviously surprise
tries to push it away
and the wolf bites him in the head
shreds his head real gnarly
wolf takes off
guy gets over 50 stitches and is lucky
to be alive
[Music]
when it comes to nighttime that's when
the wolves get really active
and i've got all these great
technologies to be able to see these
wolves if they're moving around on the
beaches
so it's time to go night mode
i don't think anyone has ever filmed a
coastal wolf pack at night
it's super dark and totally
unpredictable
i'm completely reliant on these
with the waves breaking behind me i
could not hear anything it was
approaching me right now
so i just i am completely blind without
this equipment right now
i have scars on my body from
an attack that happened to me with some
captive wolves and the true difference
between captain wolves and wild wolves
is
captive wolves are not afraid of people
so now what i'm dealing with is a bit of
the combination i have wild wolves that
are not afraid of people
so
trust me in the back of my head
i remember that day
being surrounded by a pack of wolves
what was that
did you hear that
i just heard something i don't know what
it was i got
unlucky the other noise
there's a bunch of them coming in
[Music]
looks like
we've got four
puppies young wolves at the carcass
an adult
walked off looks like the adult was on
the hunt real quick heightened face nose
to the ground definitely looking for
something
while that guy's out hunting these
puppies are really kind of cleaning up
the scraps
[Music]
i think they're growling at each other
definitely you're growling right now
right over there
i don't even know if anybody else ever
has filmed coastal wolves at night it's
unbelievable
it's amazing
it's gorgeous
this is really starting to become one of
the best wildlife moments i've ever had
i'm sitting here on the beach watching
wild wolves it's a beautiful city and
then all of a sudden the aurora borealis
the northern lights
and this is
so so cool
it's hard to believe right here on the
same shores there's been human wolf
conflict because right now what i'm
witnessing is perfection these wolves
are doing what these wolves are supposed
to be doing
there's got to be a reason out there
something's got to be happening
and i've gotta go out there and try to
find out what it is
[Music]
this is the place to learn what makes
wolves tick
wild spirit wolf sanctuary
it's run by this guy leighton cougar
also known as wolf daddy
he lives with wolves he plays with them
and sometimes he becomes them
leighton has over 60 wolves including
the animal i came here to see
a weird cross between a wolf and a dog
called a wolf dog
biologists suspect that some of the
vargas island wolves of the past were
wolf dogs
and some people say
that's what's behind all this aggression
so i've got to learn more about these
hybrids and why a dose of man's best
friend would make a wolf more violent
my first experiment catches me and wolf
daddy completely off guard
things get ugly
all right all right
well what we're doing is we're rescuing
captive red wolves and wolf dogs from
people who try making them pets
often people think that if they get a
wolf as a puppy and they raise it like a
dog it'll go up just like a dog but it
can't
we have no doggy thoughts no doggy day
dreams no doggy desires so
in my investigation if i really want to
dig in
and learn about wolves and wolf dogs and
compare the two there's no better place
than right here there's no better place
no we have it all this is your petri
dish this is an experimental place where
you can see all the different degrees
from pure wolf to total dog
i know wolves pretty well and i know
dogs pretty well but sometimes it's hard
to tell who's who
layton brings out white wolf flurry on
the left and husky dog zodiac on the
right
look at this
i mean here we go canine action
so this is a lot of stuff happening this
is called ritual domination
the wolf is isn't interested in being
super dominant but he is absolutely
interested in making sure this dog knows
that he's in charge
but what's what's being said by the dog
is that he's not going to give in the
tail says i'm not going to completely
submit to you i get it
i get it you're in charge you've made
that point but i'm still going to keep
my tail up
the tail gives away more than mood it's
a major clue to canine identity
see that tail it's it's so curled over
wolf tail can't curl over this is as
high as it gets pretty much right in
here see it's not not getting tight and
curling over
the wolf's tail doesn't curl
the dog's tail does
[Music]
ears wolves around it
dogs are pointier
teeth
wolves steak knives
dogs
not so much
wolf bite 1500 pounds per square inch
about twice as strong as a dog
and that's just for crushing bones
grabbing on and hanging on sharing meat
kibbles and bits
elk and deer elk and deer yep
but i need to know what happens when you
mix the two wolf and dog and is this the
creature behind the attacks in canada
[Music]
right now so this guy is a bullet he's
gonna come at you fast but just do your
deflection if you can handle a grizzly
bear you can handle this one tap into
some of my old uh yes my old moves all
right coda 10 foot
come on come on come on
i meet coda one of the biggest animals
in the wild spirit sanctuary
130 pounds of wolf dog
okay move
this way
you know in this investigation between
the wolf and the wolf dog you say it's a
high content wolf dog correct but you
look at this animal and this animal
looks no different
to me than what i just saw
running around yellowstone exactly
usually if a big animal like this comes
up to you and puts their big old teeth
on your arm you're thinking i'm in
trouble i mean look at that it seems
like it's like what is this guy touching
me when i put my teeth on him and you
can see that's gentle yeah look at that
look at this guy look at this guy
look at this guy
there we go
so now
in this animal that i think looks like a
wolf i'm starting to see the dog
there is that foolish bravery that you
see in dogs move this way a little more
i'm having a wonderful time with kodak
and he's hanging out with my entire film
crew right now and it's just like the
coolest thing to be this close to this
anime come here
but
there it goes
game on
bam he grabs it rips it off the camera
and now he goes into
i'm a predator i just took something i'm
going to defend it
that was really the wolf tapping into
this animal he saw he saw fuzzy he
grabbed fuzzy he's chewing up fuzzy
it's a mic today not a deer
so leighton being the great animal guy
he is comes up with the old animal trick
you want to get something from him you
got to give him something a little
better
so i pull off my gloves i want him up in
a ball and i toss it don't eat it no
don't eat it it's not food
he literally chews and swallows a pair
of gloves
don't eat it
so things are
out of control a little bit
there's not a whole lot of control going
on here this wolf dog we're in his
territory he's doing what he wants
oh my gosh
but then he gets an eye on the next
fuzzy with the next camera man
yeah he knows the whole court
here there was that what they call the
crazy casey laughs
all right all right all right
the dog has gone away
the wolf is there
[Music]
all right all right all right
let's back out guys
back out and just be and uh
go ahead and just be confident and don't
go too fast
i'll go with you guys one so right now
we've you know we're seeing
in that wolf dog combo we're seeing
a little more of that wolf
than dog
and this is the danger this is that
that's that that collision of two
different behaviors that
could potentially
cause some people to bleed and we're not
gonna be part of that today so we're
slipping out of here
but this speaks to the unpredictability
of a wolf dog
you know it's it's interesting because
the animals that i'm investigating in
canada are very very similar to coda
here what saved you is the fact that you
have this experience you know how to
react to this animal and if you didn't
have that experience that could have
really
could have gone really bad
my encounter with coda showed me just
how confused wolf dogs can be
they have one paw in our world and one
pie in the wild
just think about it you're a dog who
wants to play and bee near humans
and you're a wolf who wants to be out in
the woods chasing christ
and maybe this confusion led to the
kayaker attack back on vargas island
the fearless dog approached him and
predatory wolf tore him apart
i'm amazed at how wolves can thrive in
almost any habitat
and maybe breeding with dogs is how they
adapt to living near us
[Music]
but i can't truly understand how wolves
adapt to humans without knowing them at
their wildest
so i'm headed out to find really wild
wolves in a place so remote it's like a
wolf jurassic park
[Music]
[Applause]
well we're just uh
heading north up to the great bear
wilderness
we're going to look for truly wild
untouched wolves in some of the wildest
places on the planet
the great bear rainforest is this
gorgeous like maze of
mountains and inlets
all these
wonderful wild creatures that have been
living the way that they're living now
for eternity
great bear wolves are elusive
they're the holy grail of wolf track and
that's good news for the wolves but it's
going to be tough on me
local wildlife expert ian mcallister
knows where to go
the dead fish feast
[Applause]
it's a graveyard wow this
oh my gosh
that is all just rotting salmon that is
macabre
we're talking thousands
tens of thousands
you know it's a little window of time
where these salmon are running up the
rivers to lay their eggs
and these wolves have learned to
capitalize on that moment
they don't eat salmon that have already
died they want freshly caught out of the
river salmon
but the chances of seeing these wolves
fishing is like zero
unless i become invisible
that's where being in a dense rainforest
comes in handy
i'm going 60 feet up on one of the
sketchiest climbs ever
that tree's probably been there for
about 800 years so if it falls down when
you're up it it's just really bad luck
that would be bad luck
you can do it
[Music]
ah this is not easy
as all these branches
the angle down towards the ground so i
can't get a good foothold on anything ah
slippery
like crazy i'm out of breath using my
elbows and my knees to hang on because
my feet are sliding so much my hands are
so cold and wet
not the safest thing i've ever done
[Music]
knocked myself out with my binoculars in
the last step because i'm stupid
all right wow
it's quite a view
it's gonna be a long night
i've literally
got an eagle's eye view from up here on
this platform look it's a long
way down there a real long way down
there
finally find a great spot get settled in
i'm feeling good i'm up there
sun shining on me this is gonna be
perfect
as long as it
doesn't get real windy like it is right
now
then i won't get wet
it's hard to keep
your spirits up
when you're soggy
sitting there
yeah
i'm not staying dry water's leaking down
the back of my neck getting in little
cracks in my pants
there's nothing normal about this
it's not a very safe place to be
not on your a game right now i'm not on
my a game i'm looking at my
might be like my
k game
it's
i just think i'm
definitely losing that a little bit
and one thing i know about wolves losing
it is not an option
so it's the very early morning
i can hear
the stream
starting to make a little bit of noise
down there the rapids that means
that the tide's going back out and
that's what i've been waiting for
because at that point the water be
shallow enough for the wolves to come
back
to fish
the first thing i see are bald eagles
thermal cameras picking up their heat
like stars
coming out of the forest
[Music]
they are definitely fishing
this is awesome
[Music]
oh wait a minute
poor guy missed it
[Music]
oh he just he just got one too
he just got one too
they both got salmon
man this is
so cool to show up
how adaptive
wolves are i'm used to watching them
chase down elk and yellowstone and here
they are fishing salmon like bears
for this morning to all come together
and just sit right up here
i never thought
never thought i'd see this
[Applause]
it's clear to me now whether in the
rivers of the great bear or in the wilds
of yellowstone pure wolves are like
shape-shifters
morphing themselves to survive in any
environment
but when our worlds get too close the
wolf's ability to adapt can be a problem
because interbreeding with our dogs
can create that fearless warp dog
[Music]
now if i know if there's a key to a
wolf's heart
a chunk of elf yes we'll do it every
time you better not well let's pull it
in there hang on
[Music]
it's getting heavier by the moment you
know it's crazy you know this is only a
quarter of this animal
just gives you a perspective of
how strong these animals are
i know a pure wolf is driven by two
things feeding and breeding but a wolf
dog
isn't so clear-headed
so i've got an experiment that'll show
me what happens when you take the two
animals and put them into a wolf pack
this is ground zero for wolf behavior
when wolves wolf dogs they come to a
carcass like this there's all this meat
and that pack moves in
instincts
go through the roof i want this camera
to just be right in the middle of the
action
and there's one extra ingredient
me
well number one is i'm gonna be your
bodyguard yeah i'm gonna be standing
just out of the way letting you do your
things trying not to influence the
animals but take care of you it's also
important for you to know that they have
not eaten in 48 hours
so hopefully this will be their primary
target and not you or anything else
i count on that the leader of the pack
is named stormy super dominant wolf
always the boss
my theory is that wolf is gonna push
that wolf dog off of that carcass and
take it over
release the hounds
come on come on sweetheart
come on buddy all right we've got our
pack
packs in
it's a small pack four wolves but right
away
the wolf dog is the boss i mean they're
on the carcass quick
watch
so what do we got here man so the the
one that's first on the carcass is the
alpha it's a wolf dog so he's just again
bravery right off the top
he's on that carcass he owns it
so right now he's he's being a dominant
wolf
regardless of the dog the instincts are
there they're on high he's letting them
know i'm the alpha this is mine get back
just like i witness in yellowstone the
wolves
go around very skeptical of the
situation hey there's a human next to
that carcass
i'm not gonna move in there even though
i can barely stand it
i'm not gonna go in there without really
assessing the situation wolf dog
meat
people i don't care i'm chowing down
you're getting it all to yourself
and i kind of wonder if i slip out of
here for just a second
let the other guys come in they really
want to they want to eat that's
what a wolf wants to do
and let your buddies in
look over here
now that that vocalization was
asking if he could come in
right so a little a little whining like
can i come in there please can i come in
there
now he's back for the prize he's back to
the food
[Music]
uh
you got the air horn george
i'll tell you
i'm figuring it out right now
i mean you got to figure it out right
that means what's happening this is all
this is wolf body language is what they
do growl snarl teeth
dominate get their hackles up tails up
we working it out
he's torn
he's torn right now food
food or dominance food or dominance food
or dominance i don't know what to do
here
what do you think man
i this is unbelievable
stormy the wolf comes rushing in and the
wolf dog would not back down
i mean this experiment is actually kind
of
really hammered home
what we've learned what we've learned
here at this facility is that you know i
think that meat source with my proximity
to it i mean that represents town food
humans
town and mostly wolves like they're
doing here stay out of town mm-hmm
but wolf dogs are willing to cross that
line they're willing to do that and
that's what he's doing and he's the only
one that's doing it
what do you think
we purposely
took from the wolf
that fear to create a dog
and now
that lack of fear has gone back out into
the wild and those wolves are coming and
jumping the fences and they're coming in
town
and that's creating a dangerous animal
[Music]
so now it's time to go back to vargas
island to the scene of the crime where
the kayaker got attacked
using its speed on the rocks here
because i don't want to make noise
completely
local guide john ford is really familiar
with the wolves here he takes me to a
beach where he witnessed something
unbelievable okay so they're coming
right across here and he got some
amazing footage
i picked them up on the other side and
then came around here and saw them come
out of the bush and they just worked
their way along the shore
and see i mean what i see here right
away is you know what i would call a
pack on patrol
i see that they get
locked in on something something's
happening ahead
and what they're locked in on blows my
mind
[Music]
so right now they're in full stock mode
of a black bear this is something i've
never even heard of
yeah pretty phenomenal i couldn't
believe how lucky it was to witness this
and get it on film
we're about ready to go to battle with
something that's got teeth and claws
and right now
man they're just going
unbelievable
[Music]
wolves hunting black bears in the beach
you know they're just you know trying to
create chaos on the beach did that bear
would have made a bad decision game over
exactly
[Music]
in yellowstone wolves and bears are on
the same level but here on the coast
wolves are looking at bears as prey
they have this confidence
this bravery going after this animal
that
has claws and teeth
i've come across wolves out in the wild
hiking or whatever and i've never been
concerned after filming this watching
this i do not want to be out somewhere
and run into those particular walls
if they can look at a bear that way how
do they look at us
some scientists say that the wolves on
vargas island once had traces of dog in
them
today they believe the pack could be
pure
but there's only one way to truly find
out that's what the dna sample
but how do i get myself some warfare
without getting a wolf bite
well i've got a wild way to find out
meet my friend fluffy
the animatronic wolf
watch this i'll be hiding over there
he'll be on the beach in my snag system
his head moves
his tail moves
he falls over on cue
play dead
good boy
[Music]
this might be one of the crazier things
i've done but i gotta give it a try
you ready for this
well i think you have much of a choice
if these wolves are fearless wolf dogs
then maybe they'll want to come up and
give fluffy a sniff
and then hopefully they'll leave behind
a lock of fur
[Music]
hence the barbed wire
you know me the last thing i want to do
is hurt a wolf
and the wolves here on the coast they're
walking through this stuff every day all
day long so this is nothing new to that
he's rock solid in place
got a few hours of daylight go over
there and hide hopefully the wolves come
back tonight
good luck buddy
[Music]
two long days on the beach and still no
action
[Music]
wanna buy it
fluffy didn't get me the dna sample i
wanted
so it's time to pack it in
look right there in the driftwood
perfect camouflage one of these elusive
coastal walls
it's a full-grown adult ripping into a
seal carcass and what's crazy is that
i'm right here and he just keeps eating
just like a wolf dog
he's definitely looking at me
ripping big chunks of meat off
but when i look at this wool i don't see
any dog features
it's ears around at the tips just like a
wolves are
and its tail doesn't curl up like a
dog's but on the other hand it doesn't
seem to be afraid and that's more
dog-like than wolfish
let's see a little pulling back
using those carnassol teeth these very
sharp saw-like teeth in the back of the
skull they use like a song's grind and
cut and crunch
with their jaw pressure lions
even wolverines and bears have the same
teeth
someone will be this
but then
this bigger stronger wolf comes out
and grabs this carcass lifting it up
walking up on this the driftwood
i can't be sure if these are wolves or
wolf dogs
but one thing's clear
this wolf pack has adapted to humans
it's living up
to the coastal wolf reputation
it just doesn't care about people that
much
that wolf was eating it and they truck
it down this log
this is nasty
so i follow the drag mark into the
forest
i'm gonna try to follow this wolf
but
one step into the forest
something unbelievable happens
there's definitely a wolf back in here
so my first instinct is just to talk
back
definitely talking back
[Music]
and it's just back and forth they're
talking to me i'm talking to them
[Music]
i don't know what the heck they think of
me but
even though i can't see the wolves this
is actually the perfect encounter
because whether they're pure wolves or
bold wolf dogs we're communicating at a
distance
the distance that keeps us both alive
even as we move closer
so i have no problem saying hello or
goodbye with a how
in fact it's a parting reminder to leave
wolves beat
on the wild side
listen i've had a great time
and
i'm really attracted to you
i don't know what it is
i think it's your eyes
[Music]
so
[Music]
you